[موسيقى]
استدعت الخارجيه الاردنيه سفيره اسرائيل
في عمان بعد تصريحات لوزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي
وصفتها الوزاره بالتحريضيه واستخدامه
خريطه لاسرائيل تضم الاردن والاراضي
الفلسطينيه وقال رئيس المكتب السياسي
لحركه حماس اسماعيل هنيه ان تصريحات
الوزير الاسرائيلي تستوجب اداره حوار
استراتيجي مع الاردن لمواجهه هذه التوجهات
الخطيره حسب تعبيره واعتبر هنيه ان
تصريحات تجاه الاردن تكشف العقيده
السياسيه للكيان الاسرائيلي من جهتها
اعلنت الخارجيه الاسرائيليه التزامها
باتفاقيه السلام مع الاردن واعترافها
بوحده اراضي المملكه
هذا ودانا رئيس الوزراء الفلسطيني محمد
شتيا تصريحات وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي
واكد في مستهل جلسه الحكومه الفلسطينيه
الاسبوعيه ان تلك التصريحات دليل قاطع على
الفكر العنصري المتطرف الذي يحكم اطراف
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الحاليه حسب وصفه
ان التصريحات التي ادلى بها الوزير
الاسرائيلي اسمه لا يوجد شعب فلسطيني وانه
تم اختراعه في اخر مئه عام دليل قاطع على
الفكر الصهيوني لعنصر المتطرف الذي يحكم
اطراف الحكومه الاسرائيليه الحاليه ان هذه
التصريحات التحريضيه منسجمه مع المقولات
الصهيونيه الاولى ارض بلا شعب لشعب بلا
ارض وان الاراضي الفلسطينيه متنازع عليها
وانها ارض الميعاد وهكذا من ادعاءات وهي
وهميه
وصف فرحان حق نائب المتحدث باسم الامين
العملي للامم المتحده تصريحات وزير
الماليه الاسرائيليه
بشان عدم وجود شعب فلسطيني بانها تصريحات
غير مفيده على الاطلاق وقال حق ان المنظمه
الدوليه تدعم حقوق الشعب الفلسطيني
هذا النوع من التصريحاته غير مفيد على
الاطلاق من الواضح ان هناك شعبا فلسطينيين
وتؤيد الامم المتحده حقوقه هناك قرارات
لمجلس الامن والجمعيه العامه تشير الى
الفلسطينيين ونحن نواصل دعم حقوقهم
والضغطه من اجل حل الدولتين الذي سينتج
عنه دولتان اسرائيل وفلسطين تعيشان جنبا
الى جنب في سلام وامن
وقال مفوض السياسات الخارجيه الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيفوريل ان تصريحات وزير
الماليه الاسرائيليه
غير مقبوله ومرفوضه تماما وانها تزيد من
التوتر في المنطقه مضيفا ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي سيظل ملتزما بحل الدولتين
تعليقات الوزير سموتريتش تذهب مره اخرى في
الاتجاه المعاكس وبالتاكيد لا يمكن
التسامح معها وادعو الحكومه الاسرائيليه
نفسها الى رفضها هذه التعليقات مرفوضه من
الوزير انه خطا انه عدم احترام انه امر
خطير من غير المجدي قول هذا النوع من
الاشياء في موقف متوتر بالفعل سنواصل
التزامنا الطويل الامد بحل الدولتين مع
اقامه دوله فلسطينيه مستقله ذات السياده
تعيش جنبا الى جنب مع اسرائيل
في سلام وامن هل يمكنك ان تتخيل كيف سيكون
الرد لو قال الرئيس الفلسطيني الشيء نفسه
وفي احداث المواقف الفلسطينيه الخارجيه
الفلسطينيه استهجنت سماح السلطات الفرنسيه
باطلاق تصريحاته العنصريه والفاشيه من على
اراضيها